special thanks to squarespace for
sponsoring this video stick around for
later to hear more about squarespace the
way you judge if a superhero theme song
is good is if you can hum that
character's name into it superman
superman
look over there it's that superman
and in that regard matt reeves batman is
a damn solid flick probably my personal
favorite batman solo movie for having
such a strong artistic vision a good
grasp on the psychology of the
characters and of course its plot is
like a batman's greatest hits
some of the best and most influential
batman stories were used to construct
this movie's script and makes for a
really fascinating and fresh retelling
of them with some new and some old the
batman is a love letter to batman comics
let's take a look at some of the sources
of inspiration for emo nirvana sexy
batman and my pal chris pierce of comic
tropes is here to look with us
also my friend jacob is here beware of
spoilers shut up hey everybody this is
chris from comic tropes and godzilla
mendoza well i owe him big time because
i basically forced him to dress up like
spider-man in a bunch of my videos so
when he asked me if i would be willing
to share some of my thoughts on the
batman i said
i'm legally obligated to do that for you
so here's some of my thoughts
my favorite comic that was used for the
batman has to be the darwin cook story
ego in that comic batman has a
metaphorical battle of wills between his
identity as batman and as bruce wayne
it's a dichotomy that doesn't always get
addressed in such a visual way the film
doesn't do anything scene for scene but
it absolutely uses this as the main
theme the movie features a bruce wayne
who is just learning to be batman and
has arguably over committed himself to
being batman he hasn't left any room for
bruce wayne but by the end of the film
he realizes he can do a tremendous
amount of good as philanthropist bruce
wayne as a citizen who is plugged in to
his city's events and elections
it goes without saying that this movie
and most of the best batman adaptations
are based on the massively influential
long halloween
starting with a mysterious death on
halloween night batman has to track down
a serial killer that's exposing the
corruption in gotham by executing
everyone close to crime boss carmine
falcone
falcone falcone oh god i like falcone
and leaving a unique calling card at the
scene of each crime while long halloween
comic takes place over an entire year
with each killing taking place on a
holiday riddler's version of this
revenge plot takes place over a week
he's just really efficient like that
how do you think he hides all those
trophies
long halloween was such a massive and
huge story that both this and the dark
knight could adapt different portions of
it the catwoman elements being used for
this movie in the two-face and harvey
dent origin being the biggest
inspiration for the dark knights take on
that character see that one isn't
allergic to comic books they did some
stuff
i may be reaching with this next portion
but i got the impression that director
matt reeves included some subtle
references to previous batman shows as
well as the comics for instance one
scene of the movie features bruce
desperately calling his house to warn
alfred of danger and the phone at his
penthouse is an old-fashioned landline
with lights it reminded me of the 1960s
live action batman show where adam
west's batman had a special red phone to
call the commissioner directly and of
course batman calls himself vengeance in
the movie i'm vengeance
i'm pretty sure the 90s animated series
was the first occurrence of batman
shouting that he is the knight he is
vengeance
i am vengeance
i am the knight
i am
batman bruce wayne's shaky intense
relationship with carmine falcone is a
nice middle ground between long
halloween and the telltale counterpart
carmine mentions that bruce's father
thomas wayne performed a life-saving
surgery on him many years ago while
bruce watched this scene is directly
from the comics but is also mixed into
the idea from the telltale series that
bruce's parents may have been as corrupt
as falcone themselves the movie plays it
more ambiguous than the game by offering
several different versions of the story
and confirming none of them so it can
cater to fans of both interpretations of
batman's parents
either they were cool people that got
got by some random punk on the street or
they were evil rich criminal men's and
the local crime lords whacked them it's
left vague enough that you can choose
and both versions of it are spun by
biased parties which is a nice touch
alfred would give the waynes the most
charitable reading possible and falcone
is a liar so it's possible that the
truth lies somewhere between both of
their versions of the past the batman
movie does a great job of weaving selena
kyle into the storyline by adapting two
very popular batman comics year one by
frank miller and david mazzakelli and
the long halloween and its sequel by
jeff leb and tim sale in year one selena
kyle as catwoman fights and scratches
mob boss carmine falcone which she also
does in the movie giving him his iconic
scars
and in the long halloween catwoman
suspects carmine falcone is her
biological father which is investigated
much more in the sequel dark victory it
isn't conclusive in the comics but that
tight connection helps justify both
selena and carmine being important
players in the batman i would also say
there are some visual cues to these
comics the letters batman gets from the
riddler in the film are a bit
reminiscent of the clues left by holiday
in the long halloween and there's a
scene of the batman escaping from police
up a flight of stairs that's taken
directly from year one
finally catwoman learning batman's
secret identity was done in the catwoman
comic that was by writer bronwyn carlton
and artist staz johnson while that
doesn't happen exactly in the film they
certainly get close in scenes that are
reminiscent of those issues it seems
like this version of alfred is based on
the badass alfred from batman earth 1
where instead of being a butler use the
wayne family bodyguard and help train
bruce a lot of more contemporary
versions of alfred pull this in and
include his history as an interpol agent
to further justify why he's so good at
watching batman's back
you know he beat up superman once in
that one book that's not canon
the penguin as played by colin farrell
is easily a highlight of this movie as
it's one of the few elements of levity
in a pretty serious murder mystery
penguin is portrayed as a dangerous
weapons smuggler operating through a
legitimate business his club the iceberg
lounge that was introduced in the 90s in
detective comics issue 683 but the movie
still gives us a nod to the goofier
penguin of the past when he is left tied
up by batman and waddles awkwardly in a
manner reminiscent of burgess meredith's
iconic portrayal from the 60s
the riddler seems to be more heavily
inspired by recent takes on the
character such as the telltale games and
arkham versions putting corrupt
politicians and publicly viewable death
traps to expose their crimes and
corruption
to everyone in the city and while batman
doesn't ultimately stop ridler's plan to
flood the city it leaves the story in a
very similar place as the beginning of
scott snyder's zero year dark city
another storyline where riddler causes
gotham to be cut off from the outside
world and put into chaos and martial law
this movie essentially ends where that
arc begins so it's easy to imagine the
sequel will have a lot of scott snyder
batman inspiration if they follow up
more on riddler stuff
a lot of people will recognize a mention
of the batman villain hush about
two-thirds of the way through the film
when we hear about a newspaper reporter
with the last name elliot in the comics
thomas elliott was a childhood friend of
bruce wayne's who eventually becomes the
masked villain hush but the first time
the elliotts were established as old
money was in the 2011 book batman gates
of gotham that was written by scott
snyder kyle higgins and ryan parrott it
established that the elliott family made
their money in the newspaper industry so
that also serves as a potential seed to
use hush in a future film the last big
seed planted by director matt reeves was
a tease for everybody's least favorite
gotham funny man a lot of people weren't
exactly happy to see this guy again
after all we just got a solo movie and
an appearance in zack snyder's justice
league
besides
who's gonna give you a reach around
there is some pretty heavy joker fatigue
right now and they'll have a lot of work
to do if they intend on keeping
audiences interested in yet another
joker story i think they have something
pretty unique planned though matt reeves
has discussed why he included this cameo
and vaguely described who this version
of the joker is at this point in the
story of gotham this joker has been
scarred since birth having been born
with a unique skin condition and has
been judged and ridiculed all his life
for how he looks he may already be this
broken due to the harsh reality he's
been dealt they could definitely take
this forward in the untitled arkham
project they're developing for this
universe i imagine they'll take cues
from telltale's version of this story
where the joker is very similarly
already in arkham just waiting around
like a time bomb before becoming the
homicidal clown prince of clown crimes
under the direction of matt reeves i
trust they'll overcome the nazi hating
clown fatigue by giving us something
general audiences haven't exactly seen
before
while it's still a fresh and unique take
on batman every element of the movie
harkens back to his history new and old
with a lot of tangible love for the
character if the next movie is as good
as this then i think it could be the
definitive take on batman for our
generation and i can't wait to see what
inspiration they use next maybe support
vowels i want to see
a robin in one of these movies and not
like a 25 year old robin who's really
angsty and is like [ __ ] boo boo i want
like
here's here's actual robin and batman's
like a good dad hey that would be a
unique take
titans thanks again to comic tropes and
jacob for helping me with this video see
you next time same bat channel [ __ ]
i'd want to take out my boiling rage on
society with brain teasers and logic
puzzles too
if not for sponsors like squarespace
squarespace gives you a user-friendly
and beautiful platform to maintain and
run your very own website you can
connect with your site's users through
gated members only content as well as
sending email notifications leverage
audience insights all on one easy to use
platform you can create your own
community with comments sections with
threaded comments and likes
these handy blogging tools built in can
help you easily categorize and share
posts on the site you can get even more
from squarespace with third-party
extensions to manage inventory promote
products streamline bookkeeping or
whatever else your site needs to run
like a well-oiled machine and you can
even display posts from your social
media on your site to make sure your
followers are connected and can share
them too go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash godzilla mendoza to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain
[Music]
[Music]
you